Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos. The
first 1,000 people to click the
link in the description can get
a free trial of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
You've probably gone through something like this
before. You have a loaf of bread sitting around,
waiting to be eaten. And you fully intend to eat
it, you might even have had the perfect sandwich
in mind. But then you go grab some slices and you
notice that someone…or something…got to it first.
It’s the mold, the dreaded
hairy patches of black, blue,
green, and gray expanding like a circular
lawn intent on taking over your bread.
It seems to come out of nowhere, but once
it arrives, there is no getting rid of it.
If you’ve been following our journey through the
microcosmos for a while now, you might remember
that we talked about slime molds before. So maybe
it seems to you that we have covered mold already.
Except that when it comes to nature, it
turns out that historically, humans have
not been so great at naming things, which is not
entirely our fault. We have, for obvious reasons,
tended to use similar names to describe
organisms that look similar to each other.
And slime molds kind of resemble bread mold,
with the way they both fly around the world
as small spores, and the way that they both
creep and spread across surfaces. But this
resemblance hides some pretty big differences.
For example, a slime mold is a protozoan,
which means that the large organism you
see is actually a single-celled eukaryote
able to push the boundaries of its one
cell further and further and further.
Mold, regular old mold, like
the kind you see on bread,
are not anything like that. They are an entirely
different kingdom, in fact. They... are fungi.
And there are a few fungal species that are
known to make up bread mold specifically,
the most common of which are the multicellular
Rhizopus, Penicillium, and Cladosporium2.
As we said, fungi are their own kingdom of
life, just like protozoans and plants. But
while their growth and way of life might make
them sometimes resemble members of other kingdoms
like plants and protozoans, it turns out fungi
are the animal’s kingdom’s closest relations3
Of course, family relations mean nothing
when there’s food on the table. And fungi
are not like us. They can’t just go to the
store to pick up a loaf of bread. They can
however travel, flying through air or swimming
through water as spores. These spores are kind of
like seeds, waiting for the right combination of
temperature, acidity, and moisture to take root.
And for some lucky spores, bread can
potentially provide those conditions.
Especially pre-sliced bread, which has all
those nutritious nooks and crannies to grow in.
And mold are very good at growing. Starting from
the spore, the fungus begins to expand in the
form of threads called hyphae. The hyphae grow at
the tips, their walls made out of the tough but
flexible chitin that allows them to get creative.
Sometimes the hyphae form branches of their own,
and sometimes they will fuse with one another.
The result is a web of hyphae called the mycelium.
But the mycelium is not just a matter
of spreading. It’s a network that acts
as a feeding apparatus. The hyphae will secrete
enzymes into the bread around it, breaking down
its nutrients so that the fungus can eat. It’s
basically just a really large network of mouths.
This makes for a frustrating sight
when we’re looking at our despondent,
gross slices of bread. But when you see a piece of
mold growing and eating away at a piece of bread,
you are seeing a loose approximation of the
same processes that made our world possible.
We’ve seen this before with lichen, a
collaboration between fungi and algae that
breaks down rocks into the mineral components
that sustain other forms of life. And fungi
can break down so much more. There are
even species in Chernobyl, eating away
at radioactive material like hot graphite
Fungi, they could eat the world, if they
wanted to. But their path is much more subtle
than their fuzzy appearance might suggest.
Because fungi don’t just tear things apart.
They also form relationships—significant,
essential relationships—with other organisms.
A plant’s roots, for example, might become
intimately entwined with a fungi’s hyphae,
forming a bond we call the mycorrhiza.
And as fungi hook themselves up to different
plants, they can connect the plants themselves,
serving as living bridges to exchange everything
from nutrients to chemical warning messages.
So it is tempting, when writing about fungi,
to treat them as something that needs to be
redeemed. After all, for many of us, fungi
are the thing that rots. They put an end
to our bread, our fruits, and our snacks.
And It’s so easy to redeem them when they
clear the world for us. When the bread mold
that disgusts us also famously supplied us with
penicillin, an antibiotic that after
its accidental discovery in mold
went on to save countless lives.
But fungi, however prevalent they may be,
are a challenge to pin down. In his book Entangled
Life, the mycologist Merlin Sheldrake writes,
“I have tried to find ways to enjoy the
ambiguities that fungi present, but it’s
not always easy to be comfortable in the space
created by open questions. Agoraphobia can set in.
It’s tempting to hide in small rooms built from
quick answers. I have done my best to hold back.”
Ambiguity is not difficult to find in
nature, especially when we’re venturing
into the microcosmos. These are organisms
that speak to a world that long pre-dates us,
and in their enduring nature, they suggest a
bit of what the world may look like after us.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And we’d like to also say thank you to
Skillshare for supporting this video.
If you’re looking for a more aesthetically
pleasing way to bring fungus into your home,
you can check out the “Sculpt your
Own Mushrooms” course on skillshare.
Host Stephanie Kilgast will guide you along as
you use polymer clay to sculpt and then paint
three different kinds of fungus for a fantastic
desktop display. It’s a fun project that can
be done in a couple of hours and there are no
special skills required so you can start making
your own mushrooms right now! And there are tons
of easy to start classes like this on Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community that
offers membership with meaning. With so much to
explore, real world projects to create, and the
support of fellow-creatives, Skillshare empowers
you to accomplish real growth. It’s curated
specifically for learning, meaning there are no
ads to distract you, and they’re always launching
new premium classes, so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your creativity takes you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare
is less than $10 a month. If you’re one
of the first 1,000 people to click the
link in the description, you can get a free
trial of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
The people on the screen right now, well they are
our Patreon patrons. Every single one of them is
like a delightful little fungal spore implanting
itself in the fertile ground of the microcosmos
and then stretching their mycorrhizae out and
secreting digestive enzymes into our creative
brains so that we can continue to pump out
good microcosmos content. If you want to
become one of those delightful spores, I don’t
know if this is a good pitch or not, regardless,
you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs on
Instagram. And if you want to see more from us,
there’s always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.